all right another Happy New Year another
stretch of January movies there's always
a horror movie in these January anyhow
let's do it so The Grudge is a sequel to
the garage you think anyhow I'm gonna be
honest I saw The Grudge once in theaters
so that's many years ago and I don't
remember much about The Grudge I
remember I'm Sarah Michelle Gellar
that's what I remember and their scene
breadth of things under the bedsheets
and drag someone to hell I guess so this
looks to be a continuation of that world
and if I had any inkling that if you
remember the original grudge Oh that'll
make this movie better I would say that
but I don't I just I never get that
feeling this movie this movie fails in
its own right remembering the original
grudge is not gonna make this one better
but the premise of the grudge is when
someone dies under extreme distress they
remain this hateful angry entity called
a grudge and then they terrorize the
next person which really sounds more
cliche in terms of horror movie as I'm
saying it out loud it's pretty much the
gist right that that's what a lot of
these ghost hunting angry entity movies
are so now we have another one only this
time it concentrates on the cops more
which I want to give props because
that's actually an interesting idea a
horror movie that concentrates on the
cops investigating what's happening
because usually it's the family like our
house is weird let me dig through some
files this one's like now the cops
they're gonna investigate it actually
links to a couple of other families and
couple of other stories I mean there
have been horror movies with cops before
that's that's not new but in terms of
execution I feel like they wanted to
make this like the movie fallen Jive
referenced before but it just I like it
is when I think of fallen the cop
element the police element that's a huge
part of fall it's a police investigation
that ends up leading them to a
supernatural place kind of like a
Stephen King story or something I feel
like that's what they wanted to do with
The Grudge anything I just came across
as a boring horror movie but that's what
you have you have an interesting premise
because every crappy movie started with
a premise that someone's like oh that's
interesting every if not most bad movies
are a failed attempt at making a good
movie that probably starts with a
premise someone thought oh that's an
interesting twist or take on it this
movie is half cop movie one quarter
family haunting movie and one quarter
other family hunting movie because it
does a couple of time jumps and you see
a couple of families who have lived in
this house it's like this movie they
were like we
to make a grudge trilogy we're not
getting a trilogy Oh am just crushed it
into one movie and it gets a little
confusing you're like alright this right
right we're there now right
January movie and it's all about
execution I'm down for a movie jumping
back and forth hell Tarantino's best
film is all about that but this just
didn't stick the landing of it you have
a good cast though you have known actors
horror movie legend actors otherwise
good actors you've seen be good and
other things but they don't do much of
anything it was just it was clearly a
case if they were like all right we need
recognizable faces that people might
know from other horror movies or other
movies in general I just feel like the
characters could have been played by
anybody there's a part of me that thinks
well maybe the reason they feel light is
because essentially a couple of them are
just flashbacks it's not giving enough
time for them to be fleshed out because
the movies dividing your attention among
different characters in which their
stories take place a couple years apart
each but I really feel like if this
movie didn't do that the characters
would feel justice light it just didn't
give them enough to do I mean it's a
horror movie right so we got to talk
about the scares they're not here it's
not a lot of scares it is not a lot of
scares you don't see coming I want to
give them props for one jump scare in
particular didn't have a loud sound it
was a bassy sound it made a sound it
wasn't like like screeched your ears no
it wasn't like that it was it was more
low-frequency I appreciated that thank
you for recognizing that a high audible
sound making your nurse tense to [ __ ] up
is very different than you legitimately
being terrified that said I also wasn't
legitimately terrified I mean at this
point in horror movies I feel like I've
seen a lot of things so I'm not looking
for laying on my back staring at my
ceiling in the pitch dark in my living
room after a hit of salvia scary but an
element of fear would be good in a
horror movie it's just a bunch of crap
you've seen a hundred times before and
you see all of it coming a mile away
which is funny because the supernatural
movie but it concentrating on the cops
perspective and them investigating and
finding their way into the supernatural
world isn't that what Todd McFarlane
wants to do with the new spawn movie if
it ever gets off the ground anyhow
that's always concerned me and after
watching The Grudge I'm like that's why
that concerns me because what you
potentially have is an interesting
concept but what you have in reality in
the case of The Grudge is a really
sloppy movie that comes across as just
war and I cannot stress that enough this
movie is insane
boring and in the end the grudge didn't
offer anything new a lot of the cool
scenes you saw in the trailer the scene
with the hands and the hair sit on the
poster I can't think of it right now but
I think it might be thanks for showing
the best part in the poster I feel like
this movie could somehow be re-edited to
possibly be good and tell them yeah
thanks for the dog [ __ ] all right so The
Grudge the new one have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite and or least favorite horror
movie or January horror movie let's get
interesting whatever they are whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you wanna see more click right
here to see more
[Music]